tu la ramènes on dégage tu as vu une
lumière blanche ça ressemblait plus à de
l'énergie pure son cerveau a été
reprogrammé je veux être le prochain
dégage
je vais guérir tous ceux qui pensent
entre mes mains aujourd'hui je ne
cherche pas à faire avancer la science
qu'est ce qui nous arrive après la mort
part i à décoller on dégage
combien 38 des trucs bizarres peut-être
qu'on a ouvert une porte
[Musique]
tu fais quelque chose ce soir
est ce que tu veux tu éclaté avec la
courtney hunt
je suis un peu surpris mais auxquelles
accèdent à minuit ou sous-sols niveau
c'est alors on fait quoi
je voudrais que tu rythme car tu me
laisses une minute et ensuite tu me
rappelles
ok là c'est le moment que tu me dis que
c'est une blague
qu'est ce qui nous arrive après la mort
la seule façon de le savoir c'est de
vérifier par nous-mêmes
[Applaudissements]
on pourrait rédiger une étude sur cette
expérience tu avais une lumière blanche
ça ressemble plus à de l'énergie pure et
elle joue du piano maintenant on dirait
que son cerveau a été reprogrammé
cheveux le prochain chargée à 200 c'est
un bon jour pour mourir
on dégage
[Musique]
je vais guérir tous ceux qui passent
entre les mains aujourd'hui
un réveil spirituel trois minutes jimmy
en affectant qu'est ce que tu veux on a
l'esprit de compétition je suis la
prochaine cinq minutes 7 minutes
personne n'a jamais su que ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était si bien que ça et rien quitte à
perturber
il se passe des choses étranges
je crois que je me lance paul peut-être
quand on a ouvert une porte
[Musique]
quelque chose nouvelle image quelque
chose que j'ai fait mon job est des
débris l'interpellent repart pas il faut
arrêter immédiatement cette expérience
pour des garages
toi je te prie et j'aurais dû vous dire
que je faisais pas ça pour l'avancée de
la science on dégage
je pensais pas que les effets
secondaires alem paraître et me traquer
rien
c'était bon enfant
[Musique]